many of the people who suffered most
during the pandemic were frail
elderly and vulnerable around one in
three deaths from
kobe took place in care homes and we now
know that during the first wave of the
pandemic
patients taken from hospital and moved
into care homes
without being tested
mike padgeam is chair of the independent
care group
mike padgeam can i take you back a
a year and a bit talk to us about
running a care home
in those first weeks of the pandemic
trying to keep your residents safe
but also having to cope with rivals from
hospitals
without any real way of knowing that
they weren't bringing
the virus into your care home
good morning trevor can i just extend my
condolences to all those people i've
lost loved ones and care homes um
or elsewhere in the country for that
matter because it's been a tragedy
um yes at the start a year ago it was
very very difficult we were told by the
department uh
late february actually carry on as
normal there's no reason why we think
it's going to affect you
but we could see what was happening in
europe and we as a provider actually
locked down much earlier actually on the
11th of march because we could we could
see what was coming
but reassuring staff and relatives and
visitors was very very difficult because
at that time
no one knew what was actually going to
be happening was frightening
i want to um show you i don't know if
you'll be able to see it
there is a graph of the excess
deaths uh over the last year to
february in um uh
care or people who had been in people
who'd been in care homes
and last april the peak
climbed to 6 000. i mean normally it's
you know down uh around a quarter or
third or a fifth of that um
tell me what you felt during that
spike i mean it must have been mayhem
well it was i mean we we uh had someone
who was transferred to us from hospital
actually on the 19th of march
um at that time we thought testing was
happening in fact we found it wasn't and
we actually had to go and get the test
ourselves from the hospital
to test that person to make sure that
they weren't um
uh positive by the time we got the test
we subsequently found they were positive
and they were being readmitted back
and unfortunately passed away um yes it
was dreadful we were worried because we
saw the nhs
um was dealing with a very difficult
issue they had ppe
we didn't and was reassuring our staff
and our residents that we knew was
happening and doing the best
we possibly could it was frightening um
and
if it weren't for the hard work of
social care staff and in fact the local
authorities in our area
they would those figures i'm i'm
confident would have been much much
worse
mr cummings said this week that um
when matt hancock uh had put said he'd
put a shield around care homes
he was telling untruths
um somebody is not telling the truth
here
uh hancock says he wasn't lying
um who do you think was telling the
truth well i can only give it as i see
it and i don't want to accuse
uh i weren't there to who to hear who
said what to whom
all i would say is i don't believe
myself there was a ring of protection
thrown
around us in those very early days um it
was
difficult we were forgotten we've been
forgotten over decades
that's the only issue in social care we
weren't prepared we weren't um ready we
didn't have the pp we didn't have the
testing
and it took the government many many
weeks to actually see what was happening
in homes
despite our best efforts and process
stations that's why providers
i think without their efforts the
figures as i said just now would be it
would have been much worse so
they take some credit particularly the
staff of course
of course there was a crisis in social
care before covid
and there is a crisis in social care now
and unless we do something about it
there will probably be a crisis in
social care
in the future what do we need to do now
well it's so so frustrating you're right
um and i've lost faith in all
politicians really because going through
labor the coalition now conservatives
everyone's promised something and it's
never happened i'm a lost to know what
we can do in the future all i would say
if something positive came out of this
pandemic it's got to be
the reform of social care and rather
people rather than people stepping down
now resigning i want the government to
actually give us a date
when they're going to deliver social
care not move from it if they don't
deliver this time
then they need to step aside and let
someone else do it because we've run out
of patience it needs action
today mike padam thank you very much
indeed